all right let's go to the phones at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 starting today with our
caller from the 9:04 area code caller
from 9:04 what's your name where are you
calling from
hi there my name is Sam and I'm calling
you I had a question and the comment
about a source of promise of others I
think a lot of time supporters come from
fossil fuel industry in states like
Oklahoma and Texas because of his
economic policies which reduce
regulation and enable those type of
businesses to have drilling permits and
suchlike but yet I feel like it's not
covered now in the media Sam do you have
a speakerphone I'm curious no you don't
because it sounds like chaos listen I
don't know they talked about this nasty
personality and his clothes in character
but I think I just don't know that the
number of people working in those
industries is so large that it explains
the support for Trump I mean there's
people that work in fossil fuels in all
sorts of parts of the country certainly
it's a bigger thing in certain states
that have large oil reserves but I just
don't know that that industry that that
industries workers I think that the
influence of the industry donating to
Trump is significant I don't know that
the fossil fuel working really as big of
a piece of it the people and they almost
have an animosity and hatred toward the
Democrats who they think they will take
their jobs and then you come with the
Lord and Savior yes that's true years
and wrong not supported by evidence but
I think people always
is this all a longtime listener I really
appreciate you intelligent and
thoughtful analysis what I want to bring
this to your attention Sam I appreciate
where were you from originally Sam okay
I was born in Russia but I became
American citizen in 2013 Rivkin us for
like 30 years
beautiful alright Sam I appreciate the
phone call thank you thank you
all right take care there's Sam